[Music]
hi River babe it's nice to see you today
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and welcome
to this week's week water secrets
preview show for episode 315 chapter 50
American Dreams now first off I just
wanted to offer you all my deepest
condolences as we're all still reeling
from the news that Riverdale actor Luke
Perry passed away last Monday March 4th
as you might have realized Sweetwater
secrets with dark last week so we could
all focus on our love for Luke now as a
result we're gonna do things a little
bit differently in this week's preview
show I'll still be answering your live
questions and comments later in this
episode and giving you my three clues
for what's to come in episode 315 but
since we didn't do a full Sweetwater
secrets after show last week I'll also
be revealing a mini round as hisses and
kisses from episode 314 chapter 49 fire
walk with me plus a new interview from
lily Reinhardt before us I just wanted
to share something with all of you when
I first heard the news of Luke Perry's
passing my bosses excuse me my boss is
the 80 line ask me how I was gonna cover
the news which given that I work in
entertainment news was very
understandable oh let myself have a cry
kind of like right now and decided to
create a tribute to Luke Perry's best
riverdale moments both on and off screen
so oh sorry guys did not so over the
past three years
I interviewed Luke about half a dozen
times and he was the sweetest man and he
was the first one to really make me feel
truly welcome in the Riverdale cast and
so everyone deals with grief in
different ways it hits them in different
ways like right now but so I worked with
my editor Hank and we created a video
tribute for him and it was very
emotional for us but it also helped us
cope with this so
I just want to take a moment to show it
with you guys right now sorry I don't
know how to do this it's gonna take you
a minute to pick up the pieces
Riverdale it's a town without a zip code
it is it's got a lot more going on than
you would think
[Music]
we're not letting us top it down without
a fight
what does that say about us about
Riverdale Oh who is this guy the variety
show you remember that that was great
dad
[Music]
miss you so much dad
[Music]
KJ what is one thing that fans might not
know about Luke that you've discovered
since working with him he only needs one
take what Luke is at work we move we
move very fast but we have a good time
with that
you're a great kid arch I love all these
characters known him a long time and
these guys got a great take on him I
always like to have a beautiful woman on
my arm tonight I have to meanwhile I'm
having major deja vu I remember when
this was our lives you know Luke is I
think he might be the nicest actor I've
ever worked with I mean he is so nice
he's so charming he's always the person
who notices if somebody doesn't have a
chair you know not just actors but crew
like he's just incredibly observant
always there always knows his lines a
complete professional and very sweet
thank you I never doubted him mom for a
second you should do it do you have a
lot of cool points from your kids about
being on Riverdale I have some of them
some of the cool points being with my
daughter what does she think have you
brought her to say no they haven't come
to set but they've been up and they've
hung out with the cast we all we had
dinner at marks house and stuff like
that and she enjoys her time with them
and it's pretty good she had KJ teased
each other a good bit best time in my
life all right here we go what is on
your personal bucket list so you would
like to see Fred do I want to run the
heavy equipment you'll see it sitting in
the background on the construction site
and I'm pretty good with all of the
pieces that we have I can drive the
track hoe and the dough's are in the
front I got all that stuff so I'd like
you to see Fred do some heavy equipment
we're burning daylight let's get going I
get it
I'm glad you're here though but some
advice man to man
you know these decisions that you're
making now son
they have consequences they go on to
form who you are and who you'll become
whatever you decide be confident enough
in it
that you don't have to lie
if you could give your younger self any
advice would you know you got to learn
it all on your own I really do believe
that you know life is experiencial you
got to get out you gotta try fail
sometimes and to get to any success you
got to fail a few times and so yeah
they've gotta run it your I was thinking
you know I could go with you we we could
do this together you know we can't do
that my dad I was your age and my father
passed away I never got to say this
isn't goodbye dad do damn right it's not
see you soon yeah you will
[Music]
sorry about that river bass I just want
to let you know that we are all in this
together and I sincerely hope that
you're doing alright rest in peace lute
rest and peace Luke we're sending you
our love now let's switch topics right
now like all of you I was watching last
week's episode of Riverdale from a very
emotional place and clearly it's still
all in there but I rewatched last week's
episode yesterday and I still have quite
a few plot thoughts so I'm gonna sound
off with my rants and raves about
episode 314 chapter 49 fire walk with me
with a mini round of live kisses and
kisses now start sending me your kisses
and kisses too because we all need a bit
of a distraction
and I'm gonna be reading some and just a
little bit now kicking things off a lot
of my hisses at this point sound like a
broken record high room is the worst the
speakeasy storyline is beyond tired and
Cheryl's behavior as a member of the
pretty poisons is making me really
annoyed seeing her lash out and then
shunned Toni was just really weird I
don't like this eerie show knee tension
and I just want to stop but the biggest
hiss of all of course went to that
little kid Ricky this did not move the
gene g4g in a storyline forward in fact
it just feels repetitive now Oh No
someone wants to hurt Archie shocking
get in line
switching over to kisses the biggest
kiss of the episode will of course be
going to the one and only Fred Andrews
now seeing him be there for his son was
both heartwarming and heartbreaking and
it reaffirmed just how much we all loved
the character Fred kisses to the random
Riverdale hallway student who said the
gargoyles are mixing it up with the
poisons and the far means that line was
just too bizarre and it made me laugh
and kisses to Betty for being the grim
reaper of Realtors watching her spook
potential buyers away from the murder
house on Elm Street was amazing and then
kisses to the fact that she sort of kind
of totally tried to burn her house down
and lastly kisses to see in the core for
share a scene together in fact we even
got something that I've been seriously
missing a quick be in the moment
now you and I aren't the only ones who
miss seeing Betty and Veronica together
this season
Lilly Reinhardt wants these besties back
together too
now take a look at what Lily told me
when I asked her to weigh in on these
new romance Veronica and Reggie yes
something something is blooming there
V's bestie what do you think that he's
gonna think about this new pairing
I think Betty is the kind of person
who's just gonna be supportive of
Veronica and trust her judgment I don't
think Betty has necessarily an opinion
of Reggie too much at this point they
haven't spent that much time together I
think he will just trust that if he
knows what she's doing in that
department do it yeah I want some more
bean BC I do as well what would you like
to see them do talk but I would love to
see them talk and talk about I would
love Veronica to tell Betty about her
relationship with Reggie and how she's
feeling after the breakup B and V you
don't see as much this season which has
been a bummer I think hopefully we're
building up to maybe that happening at
the end of this season or maybe season
four will be the grand B&V adventure I
think that would be great but I wish for
that as well I love seeing them together
in any scenes that I do have with
Kandi's it's always very sweet and
people always really love Betty and
Veronica together yeah V and V now
that's a team you can believe in
I love Vivi I want I want them to go on
a road trip like they did for Betty and
or for Jughead and Archie this year what
would you like to see in the future from
Betty and Veronica and Riverdale share
your thoughts with me right now but
luckily as you all saw in this week's
Riverdale promo we're finally getting a
B&B scene and so much more that's why
there's something I need to tell you
about mrs. Jones two of her FB I never
was one for small town gossip how could
you have done something
so reckless therefore the red paladin
how many of these guys my fighting and
so continues our nerdiest mystery yeah
ooh
so much to tease and such a little time
so let's get back to business with my
three clues about episode 315 chapter 50
American Dreams number 1 Archie Andrews
is getting a new neighbor
but don't accept the sugar red number 2
Gladys is throwing a birthday bash but
someone else is throwing shade and
number 3 get ready for relationship
shake ups and a ridiculously hot makeup
that you'll never guess which couple
breaks up hmm can you crack my three
clues think it over and now it's time
for me to head over to your live
comments
alright guys first off just want to say
thank you I I'm being told that there
was lots of hearts and love for me when
I was having my mini emotional breakdown
but I appreciate you sticking there with
me was not anticipating that happening
Sidney says I cannot wait for Betty to
figure out what Gladys is up to and help
Jughead did you guys see the photo that
Roberto posted of bug head and they're
like smirking I'm just gonna say that
let's see what else we have Jennifer
Rose 95 says I hope Luke Perry's exit
from the show is done right I'm sure
it's gonna be handled with grace and I
don't think the writers weren't too
speeding having to do this obviously but
I'm not sure what's gonna happen but I
hope that it's done well though as well
Nicki West please talk about phallus Oh
Nicki every week I wish I could talk
about phallus and in this week's episode
there's finally something phallus to
talk about and I don't even want to talk
about it it's so sad you saw in the
promo you see Alice crying um let's see
bite sees me I faked sick just so I
could see this oh that's very nice
remember I will write your teachers a
note if they catch you watching this in
class tell them I said hi let's see
elegant blogs by Maddy what a regal name
said what's yeah what's happening I'm
bed G because Veronica says what did you
do or something like that to Reggie
ooh there is quite a tense scene tonight
actually quite a few between Veronica
and Reggie I'm curious to know whose
side you're gonna be on by the end of
the episode let's see Emily toto says
kisses - Nana rose because without her
we wouldn't have shown ewwww
very true we get one Nana rose scene
tonight and as always she is a scene
stealer of the episode love her to
pieces
neela hisses - Evelyn Kevin and the farm
like what the hell yeah can we talk
about Kevin walking across the fire
coals does anybody else watch the office
who's out of Pam walking across the fire
coals yeah Kevin and Pam two great
characters in riverdale in the office
history they'll match one five three
kisses - Betty burning down the house
and being happy about it yeah I
who knows if she technically did it she
just so happened to hold a candle and
the house just so happened to catch on
fire I'm neither confirming nor denying
what seems really obvious let's see
keno says this is - the plots being very
weird and giant hisses - Ricky I can't
lose that kid Ricky and as soon as like
a random kid shows up I'm like I'm out
that wasn't fun railfan says hisses -
the new serpent team I really hated how
Ricky ended up almost killing things by
dangling him over the edge of the
staircase and unity' their strength but
Ricky is not going with it
so Ricky was the little kid who tried to
slash Archie in his house because that's
normal
I think Kurt is the one who held fangs
over the side of the school which while
I'm glad that Sweet Pea and Jughead
caught him do you really think that
would have killed him it didn't seem
that high up just hurt him
I don't know but still protect things at
all cost here we go they all want
phallus I want Dallas - I want palace -
Amy kisses to the scene of them sitting
at school talking together I know right
so I was I was watching an episode and I
could tell you which one I was thinking
about the fact that we're constantly in
the speakeasy this year we're constantly
in the bunker and I get it there are new
sets and they're beautiful they want to
make sure that they're using them
I miss seeing them in the Student Lounge
I was so excited when I got to do all of
my interviews in the Student Lounge
because normally I'm always in pops so
it was really fun to kind of explore
around there at the attention to detail
that they have on these sets all the
posters for all the Riverdale high
different school clubs and everything
loved it so the fact that we got to see
the core for having what seems like a
normal conversation in the high school
who is just gave me those season one
feels remember season one
remember season one think about it so
much has happened
Taylor viene peaches and cream or Evelyn
tonight you might see peaches and cream
like in passing but nothing significant
and I'm getting last week and this week
confused I don't think there's any other
one tonight no everyone tonight
let's see carzy mash says kisses to the
arson that is running in the family also
kisses to LeAnn for being so strong I
love you a lot and hisses to the inks
between Shoni well first of all yes
kisses to the arson I know it's not
funny to give kisses to arson but go
Betty kisses to me I appreciate you
saying that that was really kind of you
and I'm still a little embarrassed today
I just cried on the internet but
overwhelmed and then hisses two of the
inks between show me Joanie Finn can we
talk
what's going on can we like does this
feel odd to anyone else it feels like at
first we were talking about like yes I'm
glad that Sheryl and Tony are having
real relationship issues and it was good
to see them explore that but now either
Cheryl's not letting it go or it just it
feels weird and I don't want to pin that
directly on Sheryl but it's just weird
choices what are your thoughts tell me
tell me if I'm off face okay Alyssa
hisses - not having Betty me jugheads
family I really want I really want to
see Betty meet jelly bean same venus can
they can someone actually grab Kevin
shake them a little bit to get his brain
back in place so I'll leave the team
farm Club know how I feel about Kevin
you know I think
i okay here's what I'll say about Kevin
Betty has had her own stuff going on
this year obviously but I feel like
Betty has never necessarily been the
closest bestest friend to Kevin when
he's needed her and I feel like he
really needed her at this point and
she's preoccupied she's got other things
going on in her life but when you've got
someone like the farm and Evelyn who
were just like we are here for you we
got this like I understand why he's
joining the farm he needed friends for
him right now and these coltie people
have latched on to him so like I don't
blame Kevin I blame Evelyn but I don't
even blame Evelyn that much because I
still find her fascinating
I like the farm give me the farm over
Hyrum Cheryl Liam I have a question
about Josie will we see more of Cheryl
and Josie's friendship will we see
Josie's red hair
will we see Josie verse Tony storyline
any thoughts on Josie leaving thank you
so much oh so much Josie I will say that
miss Josie miss Ashley Marie is filming
the pilot for Katy keen right now which
is very exciting and I don't know if you
guys saw Ashley Murray's post on
Instagram but she had her mini wrap on
Riverdale she posted a cute picture
standing on the pop steps I think she's
gonna like this but I haven't heard much
about what else is coming up for Josie
and how they're gonna be wrapping up her
storyline we haven't seen much of
cherylin Josie's friendship in a really
long time
who knows maybe they'll finally have
some scenes together in next week's
episode which is the musical episode as
far as her red hair I will okay let's
see Cait says I love Cheryl and Toni's
characters they're both amazing but I'm
ready for the end of show knee Oh as
individuals they are spiraling and I
would like to see them find themselves
as individuals I agree that I like to
see them find their find their strength
as individuals
I feel like Toni's finally getting her
independence and her spunk back I think
that we just need to find figure out
what Cheryl is missing and help her find
that because I feel like she finally got
some happiness because of Tony but it
almost seems like she's letting the
essence of Tony just total
she wants to surround herself in it to
make her feel happy and Tony is
understandably being like hi I'd like to
have a bit of balance so I think that we
just need to get to the root of what's
making sure all sad
I love Cheryl I think she's a great
character and I feel like there's
something that we're not getting it's
probably that she was raised by two
awful parents I'm gonna random uncle
who's apparently dead
Travis mystery Inc needs to come to
Riverdale Jughead and Fred could be
cousins because they're both a Jones
we already got kind of got the Scooby
Gang though we've got like Betty and
Jughead and they're like Nancy Drew and
the Hardy Boys we've got our Scooby Gang
Lea it seems like Cheryl is blackmailing
Tony into keeping her in the pretty
poisons yeah you're gonna see a lot more
weird kind of blackmailing type things
moving forward with Shoni it just feels
weird just feels weird
CJ Leon is the Shoni sneak peek in the
trailer a Shoni makeup I'm gonna let you
guys watch that because when I watched
tonight's episode a lot was happening
you're gonna have a lot of thoughts
tuned into the after show because we're
gonna have we're gonna have a lot to
talk about a lot yeah all right just a
couple more guys Samantha kisses to Tony
if we're telling Jughead and for still
being loyal to the serpent's and showing
some of her serpent roots I don't think
she'll ever lose her serpent roots I
think that Vanessa Morgan loves being a
member of the serpents I think Tony
Tobi's loves being a member of the
serpents she's a serpent by blood she'll
always be a serpent they should let
peaches and cream in the Serpent's and
it's gonna be all good just combine them
pretty serpents okay one a few more
let's see Crona
what about Edgar ever never will we ever
see him come to Riverdale yeah we are
supposed to see him by now but I think
they ended up switching things around a
little bit who knows if we'll see him
next week or the week after all I know
is hi Chad Michael Murray I'm very
excited for you to come on to the show
and we're gonna do just one or two more
hisses - Archie for keep getting stabbed
yeah this is our chief or keep getting
stabbed bear attack stabbed sliced
attacked choosing to be attacked at this
point I don't even know what to say
anymore
is it fun for you guys now fun for me
all right three more tesla does the
compulsion to burn down buildings run in
the blossom cooper blood clearly i don't
know about you guys but I've never once
in any kind of fight that I've had with
my parents or anything thought hey I'm
gonna burn your house down I'm gonna
burn down our own house
Natalie Jughead better calm down we see
what happens when great-granddaughters
burned down their homes yeah Oh better
call Betty down yeah okay I'd like to
see Josie start calling Tom Keller Tom
instead of mr. Keller after all he's her
stepdad now we'll see and lastly peaches
and cream needs to join the serpent's
instead of Cheryl I don't know instead
of Cheryl but we all need to see a big
convergence because the fact that
there's the Ghoulies and the gargoyles
and the farm E's and the serpents it's
just let's just start a new game calling
the milkshakes and call it a day okay
guys we're gonna end it there for now
that was a lot of emotions thank you all
so much for joining me for today's
Sweetwater secrets preview for episode
315 chapter 50 American Dreams and be
sure to check back with me after you've
watched Riverdale for an exclusive
interview with get ready movie Reinhart
and Cole Sprouse talking all about bug
head yes finally I'm giving you your bug
head scoop but first you know what to do
give this video a like and then hit
subscribe so you never miss an episode
of Sweetwater secrets and now head on
down to the comments to tell me what you
think about Lilly Reinhard's thoughts
about Betty and Veronica what do you
guys think is gonna happen this week and
what are you gonna miss most about me
Perry tell me your thoughts and I'll see
you next time river babes thanks for
being there for me I'll be there for you
sending you all so many kisses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]